[Musik]
kaffee auf knopfdruck bescherte
industrie riesige gewinne mit einer
einfachen technik so macht man in santa
fe mein sprühtrocknung stone sebastian
lege deckt die tricks der kapsel cafés
auf
wahnsinn da bricht sich der barista doch
die finger und muss hier noch schäumen
und frisch gemahlen und an pressen und
spülen und
qualmt und zischt es und dann wird der
schrauben so ganz langsam rauf gemacht
und dann sagen gibt alles mit einer
kapsel café olé
milchkaffee mit einem schäumchen
obendrauf
bäumchen aus der kapsel
[Gelächter]
das war nicht mein richtiger kaffee drin
das instant kaffee drin
instant kaffee beim café olé hallo das
ist die günstigste stuhl für die man
machen kann und wieder hergestellt wird
das zeichen jetzt dazu hat der
produktentwickler eine anlage
konstruiert mit er selber löslichen
kaffee herstellen kann
[Gelächter]
so macht man instantkaffee mein
sprühtrocknung tunnel was für die
apparatur kommt mehr
achtung richtig heiß geht nur ganz kurz
hier ist feuer drin na da können wir
noch mal wieder was nachlegen wollen
richtig hitze
[Musik]
so
und noch ein holzscheit das müsste
reichen
so hier wird die luft rein gegeben in
meiner feuertonne wird sie erhitzt hier
durchgeführt um immer ein sprüht tunnel
rein gepustet und dann müssen wir nur
noch flüssigkeit vernebeln und können
alles trocken was wir wollen die
sprühpistole ist durchgeladen es kann
losgehen
das ist kaffee
für den ausgangs kaffee können
hersteller auch minderwertige bohnen
verwenden im löslichen pulver ist ein
unterschied später praktisch nicht zu
schmecken
[Musik]
die heiße luft macht aus fein
versprühten kaffee ein trockenes pulver
[Musik]
mein erster instinkt café
die basis für café olé in kapselform für
den nachbau greift sebastian jetzt ganz
tief in die trickkiste
er lege wird zum barista hmm lust auf
eine kleine café spezialität café olé
mit creme mit geschmack mit dem oder dem
café olé auf seiner kapsel hier
unser in santa fe säure regulator kalium
karbonat aber nur ganz wenig das reicht
mehr brauchen wir nicht milchpulver
[Musik]
salz
und zucker darf nicht
ich mein sie haben das ja gesehen
das war maximal 1 esslöffel kaffee und
wir könnten hier noch drei kapseln mit
füllen also
mit richtigen kaffeegenuss hat das
nichts zu tun mit der maschine von
models stellt sebastian lege zwei kaffee
einmal seinen nachbau und dagegen das
original von tassimo überzeugt der
kapsel café den produktentwickler
[Musik]
o
da wird beim media morgen aber nicht
lächeln anfangen
und auch beim blick auf den preis kann
verbrauchern das lachen schon mal
vergehen mehr als 30 euro verlangt asimo
pro kilo instant kaffee mit café olé
geschmack das ist sogar drei euro teurer
als bei nespresso und bei denen steckt
echter café in der kapsel und so zieht
sich der kapsel trip quer durchs
sortiment jacobs krönung kostet
normalerweise 13 euro pro kilo in der
kapsel sind es mehr als 36 euro was
haben wir noch auch guck mal hier noch
was awesome models firma die lila kuh
ist noch dabei echt ist das euer ernst
kapsel cacau
22 euro verlangt asimo pro kilo und
damit ein vielfaches dessen was normaler
cacau sonst kostet
[Musik]
für mandl es ein höchst profitables
geschäft doch erstaunlicherweise hat der
konzern die mehrheit an casino
inzwischen weiterverkauft
vielleicht verdient man woanders mehr
geld und kaffee kapseln sind natürlich
auch was das thema umwelt angeht es kein
ganz leuchtendes beispiel denn casinos
fantastische gewinne haben eine
schattenseite tonnenweise plastikmüll
jede kapsel ist ein gemisch
verschiedener kunststoff sorten die
untrennbar miteinander verschweißt sind
[Musik]
und so haben auch kaffee kapseln einen
anteil daran dass sich die menge von
plastikmüll in deutschland seit ende der
neunzigerjahre
vervielfacht hat
und sie wächst weiter jahr für jahr
[Musik]
wir müssen uns mal vor schon dass wir in
deutschland seit 30 jahren den gelben
sack haben seit 30 jahren ein duales
system und diese kaffee kapseln sind
noch nicht mal für den gelben sack
geeignet die können noch nicht mehr
recycelt werden
eine schweizer studie belegt die plastik
kapseln von tassimo schneiden bei der
ökobilanz am schlechtesten ab auch im
vergleich zu den alu kapseln von
nespresso
denner lässt sich relativ problemlos
wieder verwerten ganz im gegensatz zu
gemischten plastik das muss verbrannt
werden
[Musik]
hinter jeder kapsel die man morgens in
der hand will muss man sich vorstellen
steckt also der impact von einer
ölindustrie die irgendwo auf der welt
weiter nach öl bohrt vielleicht auch in
der arktis das ganze wird um die welt
gekarrt und das alles für so eine blöde
kapsel am ende wenn man es unterbricht
das stelle ich mir die frage ob es das
wert ist
denn auch wenn man delay stars kapsel
geschäft nicht mehr selbst betreibt das
prinzip lebensmittel in immer kleineren
portionen anzubieten verfolgter konzern
weiter
quer durchs sortiment bietet man will es
seine produkte in immer kleineren
verpackungen an praktisch finden dass
viele verbraucher und zahlen dafür einen
hohen preis oft ohne es zu wissen
[Musik]
so sind die minis zehn prozent teurer
als in der normalen größe
toblerone minis kosten 25 prozent mehr
als die standardpackung
und philadelphia-frischkäse ist in der
mini packung sogar 75 prozent teurer
eine taktik die models fantastische
gewinne beschert sogar im krisenjahr
2020 machte der konzern 3,5 milliarden
dollar gewinn hey und wenn euch unsere
videos gefallen und ihr nicht genug
gehen könnt von unserem besser ist dann
gibt es hier noch mehr videos und las
amazon abonnieren -button da ich würde
mich freuen bis bald